[Applause]
age 13 our next guest was pulled on
stage and then played guitar with the
Beach Boys fun fact I didn't know that
it apparently led to some of the rest of
her life please welcome Anya Taylor Joy
[Applause]
okay let me feed into the Curiosity of
the question you were playing guitar
pretend with Beach Boys what happened in
that moment because there are moments
that change our lives yeah it's a lot
um when I was a kid like the only music
that I loved was music from the 50s and
the 60s and so the Beach Boys were
specifically very important to me and so
they were playing and I just ran to the
very front and I was singing along to
every single song and so Mike love
stopped the concert and said okay I
understand why everybody else knows all
the lyrics but there's a child that
knows all the lyrics Mike love pulls me
up on stage I can't play guitar at all
he hands me a guitar I'm like I don't
know what I'm doing with this without
help it's like no no just go for it and
I was like okay
greatest guitar solo of all time that
you know occurred like it was amazing
didn't play a single note
um and I I took it into the modeling
agency and I just asked him I was like
do you think I can play guitar and
they're like yeah you're shredding it
acting yes I want to be an actor like
help me let's let's do this so yeah big
up Mike love thank you
around
um I'm like 14 okay young 14. like I
looked I hadn't grown into my face yet
and I love that I heard you weren't
always
embraced at school I was very very lucky
with my parents because when I was
bullied for my looks my mom always said
you look at the inside of somebody you
look at the inside of somebody you don't
look at class you don't look at anything
like that you don't look at what they do
for a job it's just do you like that
person's heart and I really have to give
a big shout out to my mom for that
because it was really helpful
and it's true apparently that you
weren't the world's greatest chess
player but you changed the world with
chess I
I could not play Chess at all I had
never picked up a piece in my life
um but I I read that book and I just I
felt that character so deeply I felt
like I could do it immediately that
moment and physically ran to meet the
director and before I could say anything
I just screamed at him it's not about
Chess and she has to have red hair and
he hired me which is surprising because
I looked crazy
now when you were choosing to do this
project the menu it is so unlike any
film I've seen in a very long time it is
so set apart it's crazy it's a master
class in tone we have a clip take a look
I'm so blown away
so [ __ ] you will fetch the barrel
instead me yes you remember the
SmokeHouse
maybe fake I don't Chef perhaps one of
us Margo is now one of us also right
Margo
yes guess what
yes chef
[Music]
I've not seen a movie like this did you
know going into it it would be so unique
with the menu you really I had no idea
where it was going and if you've seen
that final scene who on Earth could
possibly see that coming and I was so
excited by the prospect of being on
something that original but also
collaborating with these incredible
performers I've never seen anything like
that
um
now as a girl I'm totally in love with
you I heard you like Raves you like sex
in the city you're cool you're fun age
transcends I just want to hang out with
you and please back dance parties yes
and is it true you went up to Sarah
Jessica Parker and you were like I
I'm watching you it was yeah it was a
really bad moment uh for me just because
I saw her and I ran up and I was going
through a really bad breakup and I was
like Hey I just have to tell you like
I've been watching you and big and it's
like giving me a lot of Hope and she's
like oh that you'll get back together
and I was like no that I Will Survive
that I can like move on from this and
that it'll be okay she's like okay
that's I'm gonna get in my car now
um but on the subject of Raving
ah
um I was lucky enough to live in Berlin
for six months shooting the Queen's
Gambit and their the epicenter of the
race yeah the start of the rain yeah
yeah in Berlin it's also it doesn't have
to be like unhealthy so my version of it
and which I genuinely think was the
healthiest I have ever been was I would
wake up on a Sunday I'd have brunch I
would go to the club
um I would dance for about eight hours
not talk to anybody go home eat a bowl
of spaghetti and wake up at four o'clock
in the morning go to work I don't know
maybe we start a movement we know enough
cool people that I think we can make a
club
but it is time
to start you know Raves again at
sensible hours because it's true I'm
kind of done early right so for people
with children too yes exactly
Young and Wild
you know Express Yourself
[Music]